you basically say if you're going to
treat him like a child he's going to act
like a child so stop treating him like a
child yeah absolutely you know it's one
thing to talk about insults and calls
for apologies and phone numbers and look
we're all guilty of that but i think
what voters need to hear and certainly
voters in Republican primaries and
caucuses the early States they need to
hear specifics and I'm hopeful maybe if
not optimistic but a little hopeful that
we'll have an example or an opportunity
tomorrow tomorrow Donald Trump's
visiting the border it's a good
opportunity for reporters to ask them
specifically how are you going to pay
for this wall that you've talked about
is that going to be an open process open
bidding process or clothes bidding
process what are you going to do
specifically with the millions of people
who are here illegally we haven't heard
any specific plans from them and until
we do we're just going to continue with
the name calling and the insult and all
the circus that doesn't really
accomplish any one sack Wes chhan you
think could really nail him Doug I think
we think we've already seen it we saw it
in Iowa when he was asked about religion
he gave a flippin answer talking about
his little wine and his little cracker I
could tell you is a Catholic I don't
like that and a lot of evangelical
voters in Iowa and in South Carolina
don't like it and also suggesting I've
never asked God for forgiveness once
certainly the Republican primary
candidates talked about their faith a
lot in the way that he handled that I
think is the first crack in the dam but
it's up to reporters and it's up to the
Republican candidates who decide to
challenge him specifically on these
issues yeah to go after him and do it
okay but you know I'm really confused by
the poles though Doug because we just
showed one that has Donald Trump leaving
meeting everybody else by twenty-four
percent can if you came out with their
own poll I believe it was just today
where they say Trump is actually at the
bottom of all the candidates so far and
he has a negative favorability rating of
one to two in states like Colorado Iowa
and Virginia so what's going on here you
know it's no surprise that Republicans
have problems with polling in the past
couple cycles I've been a victim of that
unfortunately but I think what we're
seeing is Donald Trump has the highest
negatives of anybody who's running even
higher than Hillary Clinton yeah but it
but again he's somebody who's getting
all this attention attention
great and attention can can bump up
whole numbers but scrutiny is what is
needed of candidates and I gave one of
the things that trumps should talk about
is why did you donate to Hillary
Clinton's campaign why did you say that
Barack Obama was going to be a strong
leader I can tell you calling Barack
Obama a strong leader is not a path to
the Republican nomination no and
certainly it's not something that people
know about as well or know about as well
that you know he's made comments like
that in the past you know Rupert Murdoch
as you saw he's been tweeting up a storm
on his Twitter page about Donald Trump
and he wrote just recently when is
Donald Trump going to stop embarrassing
his friends let alone the whole country
which I'm sure is the sentiment among
many many Republicans such as yourself
so why didn't anybody take a stand and
why isn't anybody taking a bigger stand
well I I think every candidate needs to
do what they can for themselves
strategically to rise up in the polls as
much as they can and a lot of this
attention has been a problem for Marco
Rubio who gave a great education speech
couple weeks ago that nobody paid
attention to because we're talking about
Donald Trump's latest insult Rick Perry
gave a really good speech touching on
race pretty significant issue right now
that nobody really paid attention to
because we're talking about Trump's
latest insult right I think is that the
debates come the first debate will be in
Cleveland you'll see candidates go after
them specifically but in the meantime I
think it's incumbent on reporters who
will be covering Trump and we're at
Trump's events just yesterday in South
Carolina at the border tomorrow to not
just say what do you think about Lindsey
Graham's phone number the latest thing
that Lindsey Graham or anybody else said
about them but what are you going to do
to fix the problems with stagnant wages
in this in this country what are you
going to do specifically to reform our
health care system to move it back to
where we have affordability and
accessibility that we need in this
country and that's where we'll see that
the Emperor not only doesn't have any
clothes but he doesn't have any answers
either okay well Jonah Goldberg who's
another conservative columnist in the LA
Times he writes there's an interesting
lesson in Trump's electable in electable
fate when you have a competition between
two brands the better brand tends to
the Clinton brand is simply much more
popular than the bush brand so what he's
basically saying is that you know what
Trump is showing is that brands matter
at least they matter initially
eventually voters though vote for the
person when they get to the person he
wrote later in his op-ed they're gonna
they're going to not like Clinton and go
for Bush but what is a lesson here in
the hole in this whole Trump thing right
now I think the lesson is that we've
learned is the more attention you can
get it it truly proves the point to a
certain extent that there's not as such
thing as bad publicity for this
particular for this candidate
unfortunately it's really hurt a lot of
Republican candidates that certainly
hurt the Republican Party it's helped
hillary clinton not only has she been
able to try and group all the
Republicans together on immigration but
she's not being a part of the
conversation right now Cole came out
just today that shows that Hillary
Clinton is suffering in key purple
States but again we're talking about
phone numbers and insults and that
doesn't help the voters make their
decision in the primaries or coming up
next November on Election Day and Doug I
know you you know clearly you have a you
have skin in this game and you've seen
your share of election cycles are you
disappointed with how it's turned out so
far for the Republicans I think
ultimately as long as we take it
seriously pin him down on specific so we
can move past the circus I think it
won't matter if you go back to the
shutdown that we had a couple years ago
I tell you I was a pretty bad thing for
the country a pretty embarrassing thing
for Republicans it ended up not hurting
us in the November elections in 2014 so
I think once we get rid of the circus
once we move past it and i would say
Donald Trump really is playing the role
of a bad bad professional wrestler bad
guy professional wrestler is trying to
incite the crowd that's working for him
right now but when we move past this and
we're talking about serious issues and
we're debating most likely Hillary
Clinton next summer in next fall I think
Republicans are going to be in a strong
position but we need to get past the
surface for do you think it might even
be over by the first debate in August I
don't think it'll be over by the first
debate because right now he has no
reason to get out but I think what we're
starting to see is the beginning of the
end of Donald Trump and the way to do
that is through specifics
make him talk about what he's not
comfortable with what he doesn't want to
talk about and in this case it's
specific policy it specific issues and
that's where ultimately if you would be
a candidate you make them talk about
what they don't want to talk about we
haven't done that with Donald Trump yet
but we need to and if we do that I think
you'll see him start to go away